enfin c'est aujourd'hui la saint
valentin ici philippe candeloro a offert
une jolie médaille à sa compagne livia
d'autres ont choisi des cadeaux plus
classiques comme des fleurs pour cette
fête des amoureux célébrée depuis
finalement assez peu de temps en france
depuis précisément les années 50 et au
delà de toute poésie la saint valentin
est aussi ce que l'on appelle une
affaire juteuse reportage dominique
dumas et jean bernard hier
la saint valentin est le jour idéal pour
déclarer votre flamme
c'est aussi l'occasion de se montrer
généreux premiers bénéficiaires les
fleuristes depuis au moins dix ans les
ventes de fleurs augmente des stagiaires
japonaises sont même venus cette année
apprendre l'art de bouc et d'amour
le succès est garanti l'année dernière
nous avons découvert qu il y avait 40%
d'hommes qui avait offert des fleurs
pour la saint valentin
on dirait il reste 60 % à séduire et
c'est pourquoi je fais là corinne et
ludovic ont en commun le goût de
chocolat comme à noël les banques
peuvent grimper de 20%
certaines maisons ont dû se
réapprovisionnent nous allons refaire
des coeurs et des chocolats pour faire
des boîtes et les boîtes coeur parce que
nous ne pensions jamais vendre ce que
nous avons vendu les bijoux reste une
valeur sûre les ventes peuvent être
multipliés par deux s'il peut y avoir
des jeunes de 13 14 ans qui viennent
acheter pour leurs petites copines calme
à une personne de 65 ans qui est resté
pour parfum ou livret d'une croisière
vous amuse alors pourquoi pas voguer et
dîner sur la seine pendant 2h30
romantisme et intimité garantie des gens
ont envie de fêter des soirées
particulières il ya ce retour vraiment
vers le côté festif alors la saint
valentin
là encore sera développée d'amour c'est
la patience le feu c'est
si c'est tout ça et en plus ce moment on
fait se déclarer l'écart est une foule
bigarrée en un mois dans l'intimité
je laisse à sa femme de commercial ou
pas la saint valentin est devenue une
grande fête mais n'oubliez pas qu'une
simple fleur peut parfois suffire pour
une grande histoire d'amour